yeah yeah what's up it's your man voice
to five nine AKA nickel one quarter to
slaughterhouse machine one half for the
bad and evil regime right now I'm
kicking it with my peoples bootleg Kev
follow me on Twitter at the real race
59. yeah Legend on the phone right now
man one half Bad Meets Evil afford to
slaughterhouse and a damn beast on his
own Royce the five nine what's up man
yeah yeah Kev was good with it and we're
just chilling dude uh congratulations on
everything that's man been happening
over the last two years man it's it's
definitely well deserved thank you man
thank you it's definitely a blessing man
I'm just I'm glad to still be here yeah
you know it's good that the rest of the
world finally gets to hear you know
hip-hop's best kept secret I wouldn't
even call you hip-hop's best kept secret
but you're definitely being hurt on a on
a bigger scale Now by more people which
is always dope and uh you know you have
the slaughterhouse situation uh you have
your solo situation and then of course
the Bad Meets Evil situation which is uh
what's coming out June 14th how did that
come to fruition again about it yeah
yeah it started me and M's relationship
it started with just us repairing you
know the actual friendship you know and
it went from there man like we started
traveling together like anywhere he went
I went with him yeah you know and then
you know we got back you know we was
doing a slaughterhouse deal the the
political side of it the paperwork and
everything like that while that was in
the works you know we would just be in
the studio and it started with the joint
I had called I'm on everything that I
wanted to put him on for my office yeah
that joint is hilariously awesome yeah I
appreciate it so I had the first verse
done already and I brought it to the
studio it's like what you think about
this because I always had like a a goal
once we got back cool to try to bring
bring the old M back out yeah that's
like a slip LP like yeah so I figured if
I could talk him into doing it you know
we can have some fun on the third verse
so that that's kind of what happened we
had a lot of fun doing the record so we
just decided to start doing more stuff
you know just whenever we have free time
with no goal in mind you know just do it
just for fun like let's not focus on
song structures 16 bars none of that
radio records none of that let's just go
in there and rap like we never wrapped
before right you know and that's that's
what we did and then we looked up and we
were sitting on five or six arms and
then it was like yo we really like these
joints what we gonna do with them yeah
and that's kind of how it came about one
of my favorite records last year was uh
the echo joint I heard that might be
like a bonus track on on the EP is that
true yeah Echo Echo and living proof
would be the two bonus track so it'll be
a total of 11 songs so it'll be nine
songs two bonus tracks that's what it is
man now um of course like I said you
you've been grinding a long time let's
say five years ago if you know if I'm
talking to you no way no way I'm I'm I
want to say that five years ago I was in
jail I think either five or six years
ago I was sitting in jail and I didn't
know what I was going to do I just knew
that I was going to get out and just do
the best I could right wrap my behind
off and just keep pushing and not let
nobody tell me that I'm not gonna make
it because a lot of that time everybody
was saying he's finished yeah because I
mean of course you had you always drop
like dope dope independent like solo
albums you know you'll kind of had a
ceiling you know what I'm saying as far
as yeah yeah it was like I I decided I
was gonna get internet Savvy I paid a
lot a lot I paid close attention to the
internet you know I've seen where the
internet was becoming the new streets so
I started focusing on the internet and
you know through that came the whole
slaughterhouse thing and then it was and
then it was just me starting to make
decisions on how can I bring light to
myself everybody the people that know me
know I can rap but how can I reach more
people how can I do something to shine a
light on me that that makes me reach a
broader audience and slaughterhouse is
one of them because it opened up new fan
bases joelle's fan base Cricket fan base
Philly fan base yeah definitely so you
know that was the first step and then we
put that album out it was pretty
successful for an independent project
and that gained M's attention and then
you know this EP is shining a bigger
light on me so people can see you know
what I could do and I'm just trying to
step up to the plate and just knock it
out the park most definitely
um and and yo you just dropped a song
with Primo that is crazy that second
place record is stupid thank you man
thank you yeah that's gonna be on your
solo album yeah it's gonna be on my solo
album It's called success is certain it
comes out July 26th that's actually my
last independent album as a solo artist
so is that like is that um is that like
a sequel to Death is certain
I wouldn't call it a sequel It's kind of
like a spin-off of it okay you know like
if you if you think about it like when I
look back in retrospect where I was in
my life at that time it was a dark
period in my life and where I am now
where I am now is like the exact
opposite of where I was then so it had
it had the same dark feel to it except
it'll be speaking on Triumph overcoming
adversity the things that I went through
in the past the content would be a lot
much a lot more brighter but it'll still
have that dark field so because you know
that's my most critically acclaimed out
in the day that that's a certain album
so yeah yeah no it's definitely a
classic now um when it comes to working
with Primo on that on on the success of
certain album are you gonna be because I
know you and Primo have a great working
relationship
um is he on a book of the album or is he
just on a few songs or just that one
song he just he only did that one but
he's currently working on the single to
the album It's called lighter's block
he's currently working on remixing that
right now so you gotta get M on Supremo
that'd be stupid yeah everybody's saying
that man everybody's saying that and
then the crazy part is he's not opposed
to that at all that's just one of those
things because you know it was a hip-hop
dude so you know that that'd be crazy
yeah he's a huge cream fan all right and
uh of course uh the slaughterhouse album
um is dropping on Shady Records
um I'm sure yeah I know you right right
now you're focusing on the Bad Meets
Evil thing um what is what is uh are you
guys already working on it is there any
any records done for it is there a
release date yeah we gotta we got a lot
of Records done and that's actually
um that's that's actually about about to
be my complete focus of the
slaughterhouse album you know mine and
um we're gonna get this project out see
what it does and we're gonna shift gears
pretty pretty fast
um we got a lot of stuff done we
definitely want to get it out this year
sometime toward the end of the year
that's that's definitely a goal we don't
have a date yet but I mean we did the
first album in six days so it's not
really a long process it's not something
that's going to take too much longer
than it already has it's just
everybody's kind of wrapping up their
prior obligations right getting that out
the way so we can focus and then I I saw
some sort of rumor online that Joe
Budden may be signing to shady as a solo
artists do you do you have any intel on
that Royce I don't know anything about
it but I mean I hope so
I hope so that'd be great that'd be
great if he was that's what it is now um
I I saw you I mean you always you're
funny on Twitter because like if someone
if someone talks [__] to you like you'll
you'll be quick to like
either make them look like an ass or
just go along with it or just retweet
them or shut them down uh a lot of did
you get a lot of like Flack for for
doing a record with Bruno Mars yeah yeah
that's a lot of people who just kind of
hate Bruno for no reason yo I was gonna
ask you on that song like you that was
like your your verses on that song were
like pretty pretty deep man like now
that you're rolling with M of course
he's the biggest rapper in the world are
you worried about credibility issues
with all your your core hip-hop fans or
is it just
lighters lighters the song with Bruno
Mars that's basically just us showing
versatility yeah you know like we didn't
we didn't want to make it yeah we didn't
want to make it too one-dimensional and
we didn't we didn't realize it until
toward the end of the project where I
was like all right let's make let's make
at least one or two personal joints we
got another one called take from me
where it's kind of personal and the rest
is just us rapping yeah you know so it's
like we we just gave we just gave one or
two songs to where we showed that that's
not all that we can do you know because
obviously it's reaching a bigger
audience and now ever reach so I don't
want that audience to think that I only
can do one thing so it just it shows
versatility on my end you know and it
was a good way to set up slaughterhouse
so I don't really worry about I mean my
core fans the people that have been
following me in the bulk of the album I
think they're going to be into that's
what they want to hear me do yeah you
know if I got one or two songs on there
you know of course they're like oh you
shouldn't have did that but it's like
come on man you can't please everybody
you can't please everybody man of course
you're on the cover and then you're on
the cover of the new respect magazine
look at you Royce you everywhere man oh
man it's a blessing it's a blessing the
music video is crazy
um I mean like coordinating all the like
movements with the with the animations
was that a pain in the ass no I wasn't
actually it was fun for me because it
wasn't it wasn't the usual type of video
and a lot of those ideas were him's
ideas yeah yeah and um syndrome the
director was like man he did a great job
with just bringing all of those ideas
across man that dude is a beast we got
we got the Royce album you're sometimes
dropping in July right July 26th success
is certain yeah this Tuesday June 14th
June
appreciate that man uh hopefully I have
some time to get in there and do another
mixtape man I love doing